[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en el marco
de la cumbre climática que se celebra de
manera virtual y semipresencial en
washington dc eeuu hoy nos acompaña
sebastián navarro secretario general de
ciudades capitales de las américas
frente al cambio climático gracias por
estar con nosotros señor navarro le
pregunto por qué son tan importantes las
ciudades en la lucha contra el
calentamiento global y además cuál es el
margen de maniobra para generar un
cambio
las ciudades son las responsables de dos
tercios de el consumo de energía el 70
por ciento de las emisiones de co2
en los últimos años han tomado un rol
preponderante
en el escenario climática internacional
creo que estamos en un momento donde los
países después de 25 años han demostrado
que solos no pueden no tenemos ninguna
duda de que los gobiernos locales los
jefes y jefas de buenos locales van a
ser los verdaderos garantes del acuerdo
de parís
qué roles debe jugar américa latina en
el cambio climático qué oportunidades
hay para nuestra región
bueno los gobiernos subnacionales en
realidad américa que tiene en sí misma
es
tiene todo el poder ecológico de este
planeta las últimas grandes reservas
naturales que tiene el planeta están en
nuestra región entender eso me parece
que desde la gobernanza termina siendo
un gran elemento de negociación
para acercarnos al glasgow con
propuestas desde américa latina' mucho
más mucho más concretas mucho más
equilibradas hasta ahora
la región ha estado bastante alejada de
las grandes negociaciones y en eso
vuelvo a decir las ciudades los
gobiernos subnacionales tienen un rol
importante para sentarse a la mesa y
hacerla con 26
ahora señor navarro le pregunto qué es
lo que más está contaminando en la
región
en américa latina tiene
la construcción hoy es el 40 casi el 40
por ciento de las emisiones globales
creo que si no entendemos una regulación
desde la movilidad desde la construcción
desde la industria desde
desde los residuos vamos a tener
que cambiar realmente un modelo que
teníamos establecido vamos hacia la
descarbonización de la economía y eso va
a generar que transversalmente tengamos
que cambiar los modelos históricos que
teníamos en la región
ahora le pregunto si hay un problema en
el sistema económico que se debe
replantear para lograr cambios visibles
en el medio ambiente
no tengo dudas estamos en la transición
del sistema económico y social del
planeta eso va a generar ganadores y
perdedores venimos de un sistema que
está usando 1.6 planetas para que la
gente lo pueda entender bien estamos
usando más recursos naturales de los que
el planeta puede resistir no le estamos
dando tiempo a la regeneración del
planeta yo creo que la mejor acción
económica que podríamos establecer es un
gran acuerdo para dejar respirar el
planeta por dos años lo podemos llamar
un acuerdo de economía regenerativa que
pueda darle ese respiro el planeta es
una maquinaria tan perfecta que cuando
nosotros que somos el peor virus que
tiene el planeta en este momento lo
dejamos regenerarse no tengo dudas que
esa puede ser la primera gran acción
después de que se firme la fase
vinculante del acuerdo de parís
qué mensajes nos da a nosotros los
ciudadanos para poder mitigar el
calentamiento global
yo creo que cada ciudadano tiene que
empezar a entender que su consumo
personal es parte del problema que tiene
un poder enorme cuando elige que
consumir y que no cuando elige agarrar
una bicicleta o tomar su bus eléctrico o
comprar productos que no vengan de
combustibles fósiles yo creo que el
ciudadano tiene que empezar a entender
que estamos en los límites de la
emergencia y que si no cambiamos
nuestros hábitos de consumo reducimos no
le damos más tiempo yo creo que la
pandemia ha sido el gran ordenador de la
agenda climática y eso para el ciudadano
común creo que es muy importante ha
entendido que la familia que los amigos
que el valor del tiempo y el espacio
compartido terminan siendo las
prioridades principales y eso sí está
relacionado directamente con el consumo
entonces hay que reducir el consumo
elegir un consumo mejor y realmente
tener conciencia de que cada cosa que
estamos consumiendo tiene recursos
naturales detrás y que esos recursos
están en riesgo
señor navarro gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en france 24 ustedes
también gracias continúan con nosotros
[Música]